all the things you've been through are
just experiences
that have sharpened your blade and now
you could cut a penny
you know what i'm saying flying through
the air now it's like ready for war
ready for anything right
[Music]
i'm trying to think you remember the
first time we got up i was there when
you was doing your first single bro i
remember kanye listening to it and
playing it
and talking about chris brown getting on
it well he wasn't owning that first yeah
he wasn't on it at first exactly yeah
that was before chris even hopped on it
yeah that's crazy dog that hotel the
mercer
that's like an anointed spot right there
like the rooms like i remember the first
time i actually did summer jam
with chris brown after my last came out
and it blew up
like after i got off the stage i went
back to the mercer
and hoff and yay were in there and they
were still working on watch the throne
ho was like yeah we caught you just in
time like we saw you performing
i just remember that moment being
surreal and um i remember when my album
dropped finally famous kanye was like
man like we gotta make watch the throne
better man big sean album is well
rounded like i remember being just
honored that he even
would consider that at that time like
that so that was a crazy crazy moment
for me
crazy because it was just as big for me
being out there
finally locked in with yay doing [ __ ]
like meeting jay-z didn't end up he
recording on my beat so i was just like
this is nuts yeah you had that one i'll
never forget them times yeah
and you caught that
you caught that bomb i mean people say
that's kind of like one of the most
important rap songs of all time and just
like
you know if you ask people like what's
the number one rap song a lot of people
might say [ __ ] in paris you know what
i'm saying that might be a lot of
people's answers so it's cool to just be
a part of history in that way so i feel
like i was a part of it just being here
and then we did click too right after
that you did
with hogan yay but you did that and
[ __ ] in paris so i can just that's
incredible bro crazy
i wasn't even thinking like
that them records was going to be that
big like to meet him was like some of my
more simple beats you know i'm saying it
right i just kind of clicked in my mind
to like
okay well that's a science to that you
know i'm saying people like to strip
down minimal ideas like that
ever since i mean i don't know like a
lot of people that's tapped in and tuned
in with how i've been like turning up
the last few years that's really from
going through that and understanding
like what you know you to give the
people what they want
when i was working with kanye
this is before metro mike will mustered
everybody popped off from having a tags
right i'm literally having genuine
conversations with kanye and he like man
nah that's corny you don't need to put
no tag on your beats i'm like
you know in hindsight what if [ __ ] in
paris had a hit boy tag on it or
whatever like you know and then i had to
see
metro muster mike will as far as a brand
and a name surpassed me just because
of they tagged they had songs on radio
and people hearing it all day so that
just made me going to overdrive and be
like i got to figure out a way to
connect my [ __ ] so from like into 2017
2018 is when i started just using the
straight hit boy tag then you gave me
the berserk tag and then i thought like
man i need to go back and get that nip
tag from back in the day from alert and
use that and that's kind of like that's
my three main tags the berserk tag hit
boy and the nipsey tag man yeah yeah for
sure
[Music]
i can't remember the first song we
really did i think we probably had ideas
before we did anything solid i remember
one of the first ones was
because i was working on a detroit
mixtape at the same time as cruel summer
and right after
watch the throne and all of that and
finally famous so
definitely once being twice shy on the
detroit mixtape was one of the first
ones and i was just like off the fly and
we were literally right next to
buckingham palace so
the royal family they it was complaints
that they were getting from the royal
family about the music being too loud
and like type of smoke that they were
smelling you know what i mean it was
but we didn't survive for them yeah we
trapped out the whole floor like two
floors that we was on and uh we did
you know that one that i had on the
detroit mixtape and then we also
i think we did click yeah we was working
on click and we was working on a bunch
of stuff uh
stuff that never came out
i just remember it was cool to like
see kanye to see you to see john legend
push it
everyone was just out there it was like
a continuation of the immersive vibe
like just bringing that whole
private but you know just still
community energy to the table it's like
man yeah real geniuses in their
producers like
artists writers like just real legit
killers that what they do
100
and then i remember click
what's crazy about that is everyone had
a verse on there so it was like clicked
out for real like it was like
i don't know if you remember but it was
like seven verses on there and
all of it i thought i was gonna get cut
too because what they i heard hole
popped on it so i thought it was just
gonna be like a watch the throne
you know a song or a new single or
something but then
kanye was like no hopes have to keep you
on there so
it's good like you know okay those ended
up being all three shout out man
or a shout out yay whoever had the final
say in that call i don't know what it
was but it definitely helped put me on
crazy because i i remember i dropped
click and then dropped the detroit
mixtape like the same week so it was
just like
mercy and mercy was out and don't like
and all of that it was just oh and burn
with me and meek was going crazy at the
time too
it just like
yeah it's just all like lined up
the crazy thing about click is that it
was on like another beat at first
yeah it was on a dom kennedy beat yeah
somehow ended up in a pack that i
gave kanye and then before i ended up
telling him dom had already dropped the
video and everything to that one like
yeah crazy it happens
it happens i remember on a detroit mix
tape right i was supposed to have two on
the detroit yeah we had a crazy one it
was me you and j cole
um for 24 carats to go but then justin
bieber and drake ended up using it on an
instrumental and i understood because my
[ __ ] was just a mixtape theirs was like
his album
so the mixtapes back then you got to
understand it's like nobody was getting
paid for it that was a tough call for me
too like to have to hit you and say that
you know what i'm saying but i was like
bro like i'm trying to keep this wave
going like this of course
i'm trying to
i wasn't i wasn't mad i was like yeah i
feel you like i was using an awesome
mixtape [ __ ] like i said
and he was using on his album so
obviously that means a bag is involved
and it wasn't no bag involved so that's
how i was looking at it too when i was a
one because most people would have been
like man working with bro no both no no
no key wayne ended up like remaking a
beat and it like ended up fitting fine
like perfectly so it all worked out for
sure yeah shout out key wayne yeah for
sure
[Music]
hey so your uncle was in troupe
i i met your uncle too right yeah
yeah he's a carer he's like a real
character he like
i know he was an um r b star but he was
a rock star too you know for sure they
just the stories they used to tell let
alone seeing it i would go to sessions
and my uncle used to have parties that's
why you know that i had my run at all my
parties
yeah you used to have the the
crazy parties i wasn't used to like la
parties like that when i first got out
here i was on the grind but going to
your crib that was like my first time
experiencing like
[ __ ] was crazy bro [ __ ] was like you had
like nba stars hood [ __ ]
pop singers just a whole class rappers
everybody you got gang big sean chris
brown yeah for real
crazy girls crazy kid cudi frank ocean
yeah for show crazy parties bro but so
anyway used that part he's like that
party so that's you know that's that's
where i seen that from but also you know
how old were you though i was like four
or five years old
literally bro but he like you know he
was living that life literally rockstar
so
he had me low-key in the mix like i like
literally about stuff yeah smacking ass
you know
but yeah um
it's crazy like seeing him shoot videos
in the hood at jackie robinson park like
crazy all that was just motivating bro
like this is like a reality
[Music]
i feel like anybody great at what they
do knows how to have fun with it i feel
like maybe when i think about michael j
like anyone who just is like great at
what they do i feel like that's the
reason why everybody doesn't make it
everyone can make it is because
some people may look at
oh i want i need to do this for the
money i need to do this for the hustle
of it i need to do it for
this but
imagine if you were successful at
something
that wasn't fun to you but you just
worked so hard you get to the end of
your life
you're gonna be like that was a [ __ ]
waste of my time my whole life
you know it's when you have fun with it
that allows you to be at the forefront
of development of like the newest
creativity created you know what i mean
and i just say it's fun all the time
right but there have been times like
where we in the studio that's [ __ ] fun
nah [ __ ] be laughing like we had a
comedy show yeah for real different
little whatever like
for real yeah
but when you're enjoying something you
obviously can
do it for more hours and therefore go
further you know what i'm saying and
therefore explore new heights of it
and that is the difference i feel like
in a lot of people who want to do it but
why do you want to do it you want to do
it because it's your calling because you
feel joy when you do it because it's fun
to you because you rather
do that than to go out and drink or [ __ ]
[ __ ] or whatever it is you know that
you get the call about you hey man we
got this we got these girls we got this
or flipping packs hey man you got
whatever it is it's like so many things
in my life where i've like denied it
i've been like nah i'm straight i'm
straight
and just be locked in on that book not
just because i feel like that was the
right choice morally
because i feel like that was what that's
what my heart was what you want to do
that's what i wanted to do yeah
no i don't feel the same bro people
always
you know when people see me out now
they'd be laughing like damn you out the
studio like
they don't ever really see me out of
here yeah but you also
see the productivity you see you know
you can't see what's going on yeah you
can't fake fake you can't fake them i
always can't fake that
creativity that process like it just is
what it is and that's where my mind is
right now brothers just stay in the
studio like if i ain't with my son c3
i'm not really doing much other than
trying to
elevate this constantly thinking about
it that's what separates a lot of people
from others
[Music]
like i remember in 2018 i can't remember
how we linked back up i was at the rose
bowl at the beyonce and jay-z show at
the on-the-run tour too that's right i
was i saw it's crazy because i'm coming
down i'm in the back
i see nip and then i see shawn i see
cali day y'all was all walking together
i stopped chopped it with everybody told
nip i got some joints for him told you i
got some [ __ ] for you yeah y'all both
tapped in with me immediately all around
the same time i saw a neighbor a few
times after that but that was one of the
last times where i spent
where we was all like really hanging you
know like performing together
um when cali brought us out it was like
me and him came out like right back to
back so we was just backstage chopping
it and talking about so much man but
that is literally the time that that it
linked up and
i remember he was coming here and
then all of a sudden i started coming
here and then
we was locked in right t grizzly grazing
the hanging people just came through we
ended up
somehow catching this energy to where
people pull up they do a song with me
sean ended up pulling up and it just be
fitting like yeah it's something
electric about that room even like i saw
a nod saying that i saw
i feel like nip too and i feel like a
lot of people like some electric about
that that room you in oh that's what's
crazy man and it's a few other places
that are have a similar energy where you
go and you're just inspired that i've
been in my life but that is like one of
the clear inspiration it's like a
channel that's just wide open
that's what's crazy because it felt like
when i was making music like 17 in my
room because i would have basically the
same operation everybody would just find
a way to get to my studio [ __ ] a drive
out from pasadena to drive out from
different places to record
finding out about me you know i had my
myspace cracking so like i just
i always used to just have people in so
i feel like now it's just like damn it
made me also realize like i've been
doing this i've been getting bred to
really produce for people and not just
make beats and really you know just have
that community energy
i've been in with a lot of producers and
a lot of producers don't be making the
beats like on the spot like you you know
like and be making the beats fully and i
mean obviously there are some times
where you have live musicians in there
but you being there it's times where
it's just been me and you and like we
locked in and you would make the beat
produce it and record me
and be like no you should say it like
that or like you know say it like that
or what about this you know you'll get
some creative input too and it just
it's good i feel like that's one of the
things nas benefited from too because i
feel like you guys were able to connect
on that same level like how many you
connect on a product that's really
producing when you produce a artist you
know it's not just making a beat for him
it's like you really know mastered the
art of producing and it's only a couple
other people i've ever experienced that
with you know no id being one of them
kanye being one metro too metro bowman
is like a
another producer who likes hands-on
hands-on with it what you said like
about you know me doing the beat and
having to load it up and record whatever
it's like i'm an all-purpose
type of person you know what i'm saying
whatever it's gonna take to get the job
done i'm trying to play in i remember
it's probably like
2014 like for me i like mentally i feel
like i was going through a rough patch
from like that time to probably like
2017 right before i moved over to the
studio like what you mean like a rough
patch um just like disconnecting from
the having a good music
label behind me
trying to figure out management
situations really managing myself for
years from that whole period pretty much
i did a random session like it was like
a little cash play i was running there
was this guy who owned the studio i was
working at now cash play meaning like
somebody like i'm going to bring you
this [ __ ] cash exactly versus a label it
was an independent artist yeah so yeah
he he just had whatever back he had
everything that brown paper
the dude that owned the studio
don't remember his name older dude we
was just chopping it and he was like if
you really want to stay in this game as
a producer you got to learn how to
produce vocals you got to learn how to
get a good recording out of artists like
that's the really the thing that's going
to separate you and this was like like i
said like 2014 2015
and i just never stopped thinking about
that that's what made me like i'm about
to get fully back on my recording on pro
tools started off just recording myself
like i was in here but when i first got
in the studio wasn't nobody pulling up i
had to get that literally just get that
energy going like from nothing and as
soon as artists start pulling up i just
feel like i had the momentum yeah so i
feel like that's just all a part of the
magic it is yeah like it don't be no
engineer around sometimes and you be
hopping up
you're doing multitasking and rolling
the font at the same time
that's funny rolling the fonta doing the
beat engineering
so when you say you was going through a
rough time 2014 like so how were you
able to like come back from that how are
you able to shake that off you know what
i'm saying or have you shaking it off
all the way or like how you would you
yeah
i guess mentally sometimes i still have
you know
things that i think about but like i
completely did a 180 like from where i
was it was just a time where
i caught the [ __ ] in paris record huge
record
jimmy iveen gave me a huge bag label
deal artist deal all that [ __ ] then i
want to sign all my homies i'm trying to
remain relevant as a producer i'm trying
to you know get better as an artist do
my own projects it was just too much to
handle at that time and i was 20 like 25
24 or whatever right i took a lot on
and basically going from having all this
stuff like multiple assistants multiple
employees management the biggest
whatever like to like having nothing no
more like i was thugging dolo again like
literally like trying to hit people up
not getting no response and at a point
like this probably like 2017 right
before i moved to the studio i was
questioning whether i should even keep
doing music bro mind you sicko mode had
already been recorded the intro part i
did with the homie roger yeah um
different joints i had already gated
carousel joint to travis
and i had a bunch of other stuff going
but i just felt like i just don't know
if it's going to go to that level that i
really wanted to go back to like as far
as when i was
working with jimmy and i had [ __ ] in
paris and click and all these other
joints out i literally like
it was a time like and i feel like that
was all for me to elevate and get to
this point you know what i'm saying
absolutely all the things you've been
through are just experiences
that have sharpened your blade and now
you could cut a [ __ ] penny
you know what i'm saying flying through
the air now it's like ready for war
ready for anything so i personally feel
like i am the best that i've ever been
like i can't wait to display that
you know so yeah for you i feel the same
way yeah that's the energy i'm on i'm
like man if i already did all this and
my mind wasn't as sharp as it is now my
skills wasn't as honed in as they is now
like man what i'm about to do now like
it's like man it's now it's like stay in
the studio get it done take it to that
level you want to see it at i feel like
what we're about to do is the result of
like
us trusting each other us like 100
percent being on the same page and like
going
really that's how we caught these last
few songs the last few days just like
man we just going like
we know this is so hard we bout to run
with it
i was there for a lot of the nine
sessions as well yeah
that's something i didn't expect for him
to put his trust in you like that i feel
like that's what
i know no one's gonna admit this but a
lot of the concepts and a lot of the
things that niles was able to address
you brought out of him what i mean i'm
sure people will assume that but i was
there firsthand and i saw you bring
those stories out the conversations
y'all would be having like yeah that
made me realize how important it is in
studio sessions to talk
even if you just have a session where
y'all just talked yeah even if you just
played a beat and just talked and that
was it it's like sometimes that just
sets the stage sets the floor
for something to be built yeah you know
what i mean and i saw a lot of that so i
learned a lot just being in the studio
with y'all and seeing that process of
how it happened or just having fun songs
just come from having fun too like
brunch on sundays
we literally just came from brunch yeah
just came in the studio and made a song
called brunch on sundays and he
described the day and that's like a
joint that people really been hit me on
ig hit me on twitter like i love that
joint yeah we might talk for two hours
before session or after a session and
we're gonna talk about various things
and
sean is knowledgeable and a bunch of
different things and you know i'm
knowledgeable on what i'm knowledgeable
on so of course we always just combined
in information and sharing information
more importantly like that's a big thing
i feel like people don't talk they don't
lock in and i feel like you just unlock
different things in your mind when you
get that conversation out yeah 100 like
from wellness to like working out to
like family family we talk about a lot
of personal things
you know there have been times where you
know i talked on the phone and you were
livid you were hot you were like right
you know what i'm saying going through
it and vice versa times where i felt
things crumbling down and like you know
and like really we're able to be a voice
of reasoning
and a voice of logic and coming from
another black man i feel like that's
important for sure i feel like that's
something a lot of black men don't get
to um they don't do you know they might
think that [ __ ] weird or like to be
talking like that or to be you know what
i mean
that's one of the things i appreciate
about
my relationship working with you too is
that it transcended working you know
what i mean enough for sure yeah we can
vibe on whatever level like
you know that [ __ ] is just it's real
synergy yeah being vulnerable in music
is like
it's the sacrifice you make
you know as an artist it's like you
sacrifice your privacy you know like if
i got to talk about relationship stuff
or
family stuff or
just going through real life things you
know losing a baby or whatever the thing
is that people go through like stuff
healthy yeah lucky me health stuff my
heart
i had a real heart condition that my
family told me never to talk about that
like my mom was like don't talk about
that people gonna think you got a weak
heart
people gonna thank you
all up to my mom you know i'm not trying
to put her on blast but she was like you
know people will judge people are too
judgmental out here
tell them you had a heart disease
they're going to not want to i'm like no
you tripping but so it made me not say
nothing about it and then i'm like
[ __ ] people need to hear this and
what's crazy is you know i get calls
from i remember don cannon called me
like well i got the same [ __ ] going on
with my heart like crazy stop being
right and i told him he was like bro and
i took the magnesium i should be
just being perfect now you know what i'm
saying
opening up man and sharing information
really you just got to be your true self
dog and yeah if anyone was perfect we
wouldn't even be on this earth we would
be on the next level right you know so
we here everybody be on elon musk
creating robots yeah
everybody if everybody was doing that
it'd be ugly all right you're right
yeah for real going back to the nod's
relationship like we got a similar
relationship to like you know i'll chop
it with him and just talk about life and
you know he's our senior so he can hand
me down game and hand me down just
certain gems you know what i'm saying
and i feel like a certain energies that
i get from you i could bring into his
world and vice versa so it's like i feel
like it's our mission to be this one
real thing
but that goes back to the point of um
the energy of nipsey is like
i think he's exploded so much more
because his mindset yeah it's so
contagious of the marathon continues us
being on this marathon and
you know holistic medicine like i know
personally me and him had too many
conversations about just like cmos you
know what i'm saying about different
products we're taking supplements us
breaking down stuff to each other not in
that aspect and the aspect of black
business
the aspect of like ownership ownership
the aspect of um you know even just him
selling his cds
remember when he saw his mixtape he had
for um
what table was running and another one
for a hundred and one for a thousand
just that mentality of real hustle um
you had no choice but to honor and
respect every aspect of that right so we
carry that on
that authenticity
that authenticity he just was real with
it right so
i mean i really do be in that studio
like nah
nip wouldn't like
this ain't some [ __ ] nip would rock with
like i really think that sometimes you
know not i mean honestly bro not even on
no extra weird [ __ ] but like i feel like
his energy is definitely still around
like
just him coming to the stool and just
like you know just being like bro i
don't know what it is about this room
like i really like just love being in
here man and like
he felt that same thing you feel or
knives or whoever come through it's like
something about it and
man it's just crazy to to just see
how every day we get to take advantage
of that energy man anybody who ever had
a chance to encounter him experience
his work ethic his mindset his
vulnerability his vision he was working
on victory lap for
years like years and years and years and
years and years and people were looking
at him crazy bro let's not get the fact
that a lot of people around him were
looking at him crazy like bro
you've been working on this for seven
years or however long he was working on
it right but when you listen back to it
it's a pure classic
that always gives me the confidence to
stand my ground for what i believe in if
it's people around me like you need to
do this you need that you need to have a
club song you need to do this man you
tripping you need the [ __ ] man
you drop the album it's like
i to stick to my ground and stick to my
guns and that's something i learned and
really think about with it man like he
really did that his whole career yeah
you know life yeah
and he a legend for it
just an opinion of mine not a factual
thing but i really feel like you
probably would have done a
whole nipsy hustle album you know what
i'm saying i mean
that's the crazy thing is we spoke about
that
the same way me and you talking me and
nas talk like he was hitting me at eight
nine in the morning you know just like
sending me sample ideas like chop this
up i tell them like i'm gonna have it
chopped up by the afternoon pull up
let's get it done whatever honestly i'm
not gonna lie even just the last few
days of us recording have been like i
feel like we have
yeah i feel like we hit a new level for
real mm-hmm
it's like oh [ __ ] right now it's like
okay let's stick to this let's keep this
[ __ ] going because yeah the energy is so
high
yeah i don't know what happened either
like it was going really good like we
had like a lot of stretching momentum
yeah but something happened like we
didn't say we walked through a portal a
few days ago like
so it's ironic that they don't feel like
i'm literally in it right yeah i know
like me too even
the song we did last night but it's
ironic that we're doing this interview
now just a few days into like
you know
the new energy to me it's like the best
creative experiences that i've been in
either in my life or in a long time so
no same here yeah like i just feel like
it's
not to say easy but like the we didn't
done so many ideas now it's just coming
to us and at a different pace and
it's feeling right though it's feeling
elevated i've been thinking about it
every day i play the songs bro like i
wake up i'm on the phone playing it off
the phone i hop in the whip go to my
workout i'm playing i'm playing the
joints
it's just like man i'm really tapped
into trying to just
elevate everything to the highest
possible level yeah and that's and i'm
right there with you so it's like we
both trying to elevate it you bro like
to me i'm like you didn't wrote some of
your best raps in the last couple days
that's scary
cause
bro got too many verses too many bars
like he wanted them dudes that just come
modern with the flow every time and
catch you off guard you're not doing
nothing that's predictable and that's
what i super respect about you know i'm
saying what you do yeah you man
appreciate that you too like as a
producer i literally feel the exact same
way you said just like
unpredictable like you get in a pocket
that could sound like it's right in
pocket but it's something new it's
something like it's something that
is textured or something that's just not
it's like going to like the highest
level of like
cloth you know what i'm saying it's like
you're in streetwear and then you get
the highest couture louis vuitton
it just feels like you master like both
of them though it feels like you know
how to tap into so many different like
what whole said hope so you like a swiss
army knife like you got so many
different what you know what i mean
crazy crazy yeah good talk bro yes sir
you know i'm dapping you up like we're
not gonna go in the next room
but yeah i mean i'm excited we got a lot
of work to do got a lot of music to give
to people we've got an important job
it's on my mind 24 7 bro yeah i'm locked
in with you for sure yeah let's go